[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جمبو وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع
احداث وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من شمال ام
درمان والمشهد في ختام يوم من الاشتباكات
العنيفه في مدن العاصمه السودانيه ثلاث
فور انتهاء مهله استمرت يوما واحدا
والى طهران هناك دعا المرشد الاعلى
الايراني علي خلال لقاء مع المسؤولين عن
البرنامج النووي الى مواصله التعاون مع
الوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
والصوره من الدار البيضاء وتحديدا من خارج
ملعب محمد الخامس الذي يجمع الاهل المصري
والوداد البيضاوي المغربي في اياد نهائي
دوري ابطال افريقيا الشوط الاول انتهى
بتقدم الوداد بهدف دون مقابل
والشوط الثاني يبدا بعد قليل
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
فور انتهاء هدنه استمرت 24 ساعه معارك
وصفت بالاعنف منذ اسابيع في مدن العاصمه
السودانيه الثلاث اشتباكات وقصف بالمدفعيه
وضربات جويه ودعوات افريقيه الى وقف فوري
لاطلاق النار عشيه قمه للايجاد في جيبوتي
[موسيقى]
بعد يوم من اعلان زيلينسكي بدا عمليات
هجوميه مضاده
تعلن استعاده السيطره على ثلاث بلدات في
دونات
وموسكو تقول ان القوات الروسيه صدت ثمان
هجمات للجيش الاوكراني على محور دونتس
وثلاثا على محور زابورجيا
مشددا على عدم المسي بالبنيه التحتيه
لصناعه النوويه خامنا يدعو الى استمرار
تعاون طهران مع الوكاله الذريه بشان
البرنامج النووي ويقول انه لا ضير في
ابرام اتفاق النووي مع الغرب ومن واشنطن
تمسك بالمسار الدبلوماسي مع ايران وتاكيد
على منعها من امتلاك سلاح نووي مع الابقاء
على الخيارات كافه
[موسيقى]
في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه
ناقشنا سياقه وتداعيات اشتداد واتساع نطاق
المعارك بين الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم
السريه فور انتهاء مهله اليوم الواحد بين
الطرفين في وقت مبكر من صباح اليوم
والاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا
قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم ما
دلالات اشتداد واتساع نطاق المعارك في
السودان فور انتهاء هدنه اليوم الواحد
وجاءت الاجابات على النحو التالي نحو 25%
اعتبروا التصعيد الميداني مؤشرا على تعثر
مسارات التفاوض قرابه 41% قالوا ان
التصعيد دليل على ان الخيار العسكري
سيتصدر المشهد بينما صوت
34% ان التصعيد مؤشر على اتساع هوه الخلاف
بين طرفي القتال هذا سؤال سيبقى مطروحا
على منصاتنا الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه
التص ويت عبر دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا على
المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق خلاله
لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعل عربيا ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
خلال زياره وفد رفيع المستوى للاتحاد
الاوروبي يعرضوا على تونس مساعده لانعاش
الاقتصاد والحد من الهجره ومنظمات حقوقيه
تونسيه تقول ان التحرك الاوروبي عنوانه
الاموال والمساعدات مقابل دور شرطي الحدود
[موسيقى]
ما ان انتهت هدنه استمرت يوما واحدا بين
الجيش السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع حتى
اشتعلت الاشتباكات بين الطرفين في اكثر من
منطقه كان لافتا اتساع للشباكات لتشمل
مناطق جديده في العاصمه الخرطوم ومع تطور
الوضع بشكل ملحوظ واستخدام مكثف للاسلحه
والخصف الجوي تعيش الجنينه عاصمه غرب
دارفور وضعا خطيرا مع استمرار الاشتباكات
واتخاذها بعدا قبليا تسببت في مقتل المئات
سحب دخان متصاعد منذ ايام في محيط مجمع
اليرموك للصناعات العسكريه جنوبيه العاصمه
السودانيه بعد اندلاع حريق جرى انفجار في
مستودعات النفط والغاز الرئيسيه القريبه
من المجمع هناك اندلعت معارك بين الجيش
السوداني وقوه الدعم السريع لكن الحريق
صوره مصغره لحريق اكبر لم يمهل الهدنه
ساعه بعد انتهائها حتى احتدمت المعارك بين
الطرفين في مدن العاصمه السودانيه الثلاث
الخرطوم والخرطوم بحري وام درمان بالاسلحه
الثقيله ومشاركه الطائره الحربيه في مدينه
الخرطوم بحريق ست طائره الجيش نقاط
التمركز قوات الدعم السريع وذلك في جسر
الحلفايه شماليه المدينه الجسر الرابط بين
الخرطوم بحري وام درمان من الناحيه
الشرقيه يحمل اهميه استراتيجيه اذ يشكل
نقطه ارتكاز ومعبرا مهما بين المدينتين
وتحدثت مصادر ع عن تمكن الجيش السوداني من
الوصول اليه والتمركز في مدخله في اعقاب
هجومه عبر اكثر من محور امتدت الاشتباكات
العنيفه لتشمل بعض المواقع قرب شارع
الستين وانتقلت لمواقع لم يعهد عليها
الاشتباك من قبل مثل منطقه الحاج يوسف
بشرق النيل حيث استمرت المعارك ومنطقه
الجريف معارف عنيفه بالاسلحه الثقيله وقعت
ايضا في المنطقه الصناعيه وسط العاصمه
وحيي الحله الجديده والرميله وتعرضت مناطق
مثل الازهري جنوبي الخرطوم لقصف المدفعي
في الجانب الاخر انفجارات قويه ومتتاليه
سمعت جنوبيه مدينه ام درمان وذلك بعد اقل
من ساعه من انتهاء هدنه اتت برعايه سعوديه
امريكيه
لا يمكن فصل هذه التطورات خصوصا في
العاصمه عن تفاقم الوضع بشكل خطير في
مدينه الجنينه عاصمه ولايه غربارفور واخذت
بعدا قبليا حتى شبهت نقابه اطباء غرب
دارفور الوضع بمجازر رواندا العرقيه عام
وحسب بيان للنقابه فقد قتل اكثر من الف
شخص بسبب الاشتباكات بينهم اطفال فقدوا
حياتهم بسبب الجوع وضع تسبب في نزوح نحو
100 الف شخص الى دوله تشاد المجاوره وعدد
من المناطق الداخليه في اقليم دارفور
ينضم الينا من باريس محمد تورشينا الكاتب
والباحث السياسي السوداني مرحبا بك سيد
محمد كان لافتا اتساع المعارك واشتداد هذه
المعارك مباشره فوق ثوره انتهاء هدنه
الاربع وعشرين ساعه هل من قرار مستجد لدى
طرفي القتال اتخذ بعد هذه الهدنه
التحيه لكل الساده المشاهدين الكرام انا
في تقديري وبالرجوع الى التصريحات
الاعلاميه التي صدرت من قاعده الجيش رئيس
مجلس السياده عبد الفتاح البرهان او شمس
الدين كباش القائد الثاني فضلا عن تصريحات
عبد الرحيم
قائد ثاني الدعم السريع كلها تصب في ان ما
زال الطرفان يعتمدان على استراتيجيه الحسم
العسكري في ظل التراجع او عدم
التفعيل المساعي التي تزعي الى اغرار وقف
دائم لاطلاق النار او وقفي طويل الامد
بالرغم من انه ابنه الامس حققت نجاح نسبه
بالرغم ان الاحداث في الجنينه ما زالت
مستمره فانا في تقديري هذا ربما يؤشر الى
التصريحه تهديد الذي اطلقه رئيس مجلس
السياده بانهم سيستخدمون القوه العموميته
وذلك يبدو بانا من خلال انتشار الجيش في
عدد من المحاور ودخول معارك متعدده في ظل
ايضا فكان رغبه الدعم السريع في السيطره
على مجمع اليرموك العسكري بعد بعد حوالي
شهرين من اندل اع هذه الاشتباكات هل هناك
ما يؤشر الى امكانيه حسم عسكري لاي من
الطرفين برايك
انا في تقدير هذه الجزئيه تحديدا مرتبطه
بقدره كل طرف في الحصول على الامداد في
كذلك في المخزون البشري هنا يبدو ان
التفوق للجيش السوداني بحيث ان ما زالت
هنالك العديد من المناطق العسكريه لم تاتي
الى الخرطوم ما زالت متواجده في مناطقها
فضلا عن ذلك هذه الكميات الكبيره التي
انتشرت اليوم من القوات المسلحه يبدو انها
كانت ربما في فتره اعداد او تدريب لاسيما
في استراتيجيات الحرب الخاطفه او
استراتيجيات حرب المدن لان هذه القوات
لاحظناها من اليوم الاول اتت من العديد من
ولايه السودان لكنها اختفت وربما كانت في
القاعده الجويه في وادي سيدنا او في منطقه
المدرعات العسكريه الخرطوم وغيرها من
المناطق العسكريه كمنطقه فتاش ولكن
الاشتباكات يعني حتى حتى لو لو لو
قدر الامر في الخرطوم على النحو الذي
ذكرته لكن هناك ما يدل على امكان انتقال
هذا الاقتتال الى اماكن اخرى والجنينه
اكبر دليل في ولايه غرب دارفور
الدعم السريع منزلها للاولى كانوا يراهن
على استيلاء على السلطه في الخرطوم
تقديم الخيارات العسكريه الى محاكمه الى
ذلك من خلال تصريحات القيادات العسكريه
للدعم السريع لكن ربما هذه الاستراتيجيه
الان اصبحت في طير النسيان ربما الان يلقى
الدعم السريع الى في تقدير السيناريو
الاول وهذا ملموس من خلال الجولات التي
تقوم بها قيادات الدعم السريع لاسيما من
خلال العوده الى اوضاع ما قبل 15 ابريل
بان تعود الاوضاع وان يعود الدعم السريع
ومحمد حمدان دقله ان كان على قيد الحياه
نائبا لرئيس مجلس السياده في الاتجاه
الاخر اذا فشلت هذه المسائل بلا شك ربما
يتقهر ويتراجع عناصر الدعم السريع الى الى
دارفور او الى كردفان باعتبار هذه تشكل
حواضر اجتماعيه وبها العديد من الالات
الظروف الطبيعيه التي تعقد طبيعه القتال
بالنظومه التقليديه او بالنظم المتعارف
عليها من قبل الجيش والجيش كذلك لم يستطيع
ان يحسم او يتحر التمرد لابسط هنا الحركات
المسلحه في في دارفور وفي كردفان فبالتالي
ربما يتراجعون الى تلك المناطق لكن انا في
تقديره اذا لجوا الى هذا الخيار النتيجه
ايضا لسهوله وصول الامداد والدعم سواء
افريقي الوسطى لكن ربما اذا لجوا لهذا
الخيار ربما تكون هنالك ايضا مطامع وابعاد
او مطالبه بحق تقرير او كردفان شكرا لك
محمد تروشين الكاتب والبحث سياسي السوداني
حدثنا من باريس
قال الناطق باسم الجيش السوداني العميد
نبيل عبد الله ان قوات الجيش نفذت عمليه
تمشيط في مناطق عذاب العاصمه الخرطوم ضمن
خطه للتخلص مما وصفه بتمرد مشيرا الى ان
العمليه حققت هدفها على حد تعبيره
بعمليات تمشيط في مناطق متفرقه من العاصمه
وتاتي هذه العمليات في اطار
القضاء على هذا التمرد اما يهم في الامر
ان هذه العمليات الحمد لله كانت ناجحه
تماما طبعا لاحظنا بيان اصدره المتمردون
وفيه الكثير من الاكاذيب طبعا
تحدثوا عن تدمير قوات تحدثوا عن
تدمير القوات في المدرعات تحدثوا عن
مهاجمه قوات من قواتنا وكل هذا غير صحيح
طبعا
تعقد منظمه الايجاد قمه غدا في جيبوتي
تبحث قضايا افريقيه في مقدمتها الوضع في
السودان وكان جيبوتي قد استضافت قمه
افريقيه مصغره اليوم حضرها رؤساء جنوب
السودان وكينيا وجيبوتي واقل الرئيس
الجيبوتي اسماعيل عمر جيلي ان دول الايجاد
ستدرس سبل اقناع طرفي الازمه في السودان
باجراء حوار كفيل بوقت اطلاق النار بشكل
فعلي من جهته وصف الرئيس الكني ويليام
روتو الوضع في السودان بالسيء وبانه يزداد
تعقيدا
بشان الوضع في السودان من الواضح انه منذ
قمه الايجاده الاخيره لم يتحسن الوضع على
الاطلاق على العكس فهو يزداد سوءا حيث
استمر القتال بين الجنرانين وقوتهما في
قمهنا غدا امل ان نتمكن من الاتفاق على
كيفيه معالجه هذا الامر لان الخسائر في
الارواح والوضع الانساني وقصف الجسور
والمستشفيات والمباني يعتبر خساره كبيره
لنا كشعب في هذه القاره وبالتالي نحن
مدينون لاهل السودان ان نتقدم القياده
لوقف هذه الحرب والسماح لهم باجراء
محادثات حول مستقبل بلدهم
لاحقا مشاهدينا في فقره المتابعه نسلط
الضوء على حرب الجسور في اشتباكات السودان
ونسال ضيف الحصاد عن اهميتها الميدانيه
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هنا مليار نائبه وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني استعاده الجيش الاوكراني
السيطره على قريه
ماكاروفكا في منطقه
ليرتفع عدد البلدات المستعاده في تلك
المنطقه اليوم الى ثلاثه الجيش الاوكراني
كان قد اعلن استعاده السيطره على بلده
نيسكو شنوي في دونتسك في اطار عملياته
الهجوميه في الجبهه الشرقيه ونشرت القوات
الاوكرانيه مقطعا مصورا لجنودها يعلنون
السيطره على البلده كانت القوات
الاوكرانيه قد اعلنت استعاده بلده بلاغو
ديتني الواقعه شمالي بخموت وانسحاب القوات
الروسيه منها
كما نشرت قياده القوات البريه الاوكرانيه
مقطعا مصورا يظهر مقاله انه تقدم لجنودها
واستعادتهم موقعا من القوات الروسيه في
اتجاه مدينه
كما قالت القوات الاوكرانيه ان القوات
الروسيه رجعت نحو 15 كلم بعد تفجير سدك
خفك في خرسون جنوبيه البلاد كانت القوه
الاوكرانيه قالت انها قصفت مواقع عسكريه
روسيه واسقطت اربع طائرات روسيه مسيره
خلال المعارك في خرسون بينما اعلنت وزاره
الدفاع الاوكرانيه ان روسيا بدات نقل
وحدات من النخبه من خييرسون الى زابولوجيا
وباخموت وتحديدا من قوات البحريه والقوات
المحموله جوا
تحركات عسكريه ناشطه تشهدها محاور بخموت
في وقت تحدث فيه الرئيس الاوكراني
عن تنفيذ عمليات هجوميه ودفاعيه مضاده
وعلى الرغم من عدم تقديم زيلينسكي اي
معلومات مفصله عن مرحله الهجوم فان
التطورات المدنيه تقدم تصورا محتملا
لمحاور الهجوم التفاصيل نتابعها في
التقرير التالي
تجهز اوكرانيا منذ شهور بهجومها المضاد
الذي تعول عليه لاستعاده مناطق تحت
السيطره الروسيه في الجبهات الشرقيه
والغربيه
وسعت من نطاق ضرباتها بقصف صاروخي طويل
المدى اصاب اهدافا روسيه بعيده عن الخطوط
الاماميه ثم تحركت فرق صغيره نسبيا من
الوحدات الاوكرانيه المدرعه عبر الحقول
المفتوحه باتجاه جنوب شرق زقروشيا في
محاوله جاده لاستطلاع الدفاعات الروسيه
عند نقاط عده على طول خط التماس فما
السيناريوهات المحتمله للهجوم المضاد
تتوزع العمليات القتاليه على عده محاور في
محاوله لتوسيع رقعه استجابه الجيش الروسي
شرقيه
تشهد الجبهه الممتده على طول قرابه 15
كيلو مترا اشتباكات مستمره في اي خاف جنوب
شرق سابولوجيا ايضا دفعت كييف ارتالا من
الدبابات والمدرعات ونقلات الجند الى
منطقه ممتده لنحو 12 كيلومترا في محاولات
لاقتحام الدفاعات الروسيه في محيط بخموت
تحاول القوات المهاجمه اختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه في اتجاه كرسنالورا شماليه ضخمه
وكليتشيفكا جنوبا
شمالا حركه النشطه للقوات الاوكرانيه في
شرقي كوبيانسك
بالتزامن تنشط العمليات شماليه مكيفكا مع
محاولات اختراق في مناطق جنوب افديافكا
وفي اقصى الشرق تستمر المعارك في ذلك
اللتين تشكلان نقطتين مهمتين ستحاول
اوكرانيا عبرهما اختراق الخطوط الروسيه
تهدف القوات الاوكرانيه اضافه لتشتيت
انتباه الجيش الروسي الى احداث ثغره
واختراق يفصل بين الجبهتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه في اقليم دومباس عند ميلتوبول
وماريوبول وسبولوجيا ما يمهد لاحقا في حال
نجاح الهجوم للوصول لشواطئ بحر ازوف
وتهديد البحريه الروسيه في قواعد شبه
جزيره القرم هذا بدوره قد يستتبع اضطرابا
في خطوط امداد القوات الروسيه هذا
السيناريو المحتمل للهجوم الاوكراني بدا
يشهد بعض العراقيل
ابرزها تفجير سدك خوفكا الذي يقدر خبراء
انه سيؤخر اي هجوم اوكراني محتمل في هذا
الاتجاه وهو ادى بالفعل الى تراجع القوات
الروسيه عن اماكن تموضعها
يضاف الى ذلك الخسائر التي تتعرض لها
القوات المهاجمه نتيجه وجود دفاعات روسيه
محكمه في نقاط واسعه قائمه منذ السيطرتها
على هذه المناطق وانخفاض قدره سلاح الجو
الاوكراني على تامين غطاء للقوات المهاجمه
[موسيقى]
فلا يوري ساكن مستشر وزير دفاع الاوكراني
والمتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع ان الاسلحه
الغربيه التي تلقتها اوكرانيا تلعب دورا
كبيرا في المعارك على الارض واشار في
مقابلات مع الجزيره الى انما اعتبره تقدما
تحرزه قوه بلاده مجرد بدايه حسب تعبيره
الاسلحه الغربيه التي تلقيناها من حلفائنا
تلعب دورا مهما في المعارك لانها اكثر دقه
لدينا صواريخ بعيده المدى ودبابات مزوده
برؤيه ليليه ومدرعه بشكل افضل كل هذه
الاسلحه تدرب عليها جنودنا وباتت جزءا من
العمليات القتاليه
في مقابل روايات التقدم الاوكرانيه تعلن
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها صدت ثماني
هجمات للجيش الاوكراني في دونيسك وهجومين
في محور سوليدار
وثلاثه اخرى على محور زابولوجيا كما قالت
ان البحريه الروسيه افشلت هجوما اوكرانيا
بزوارق مسيره على سفينه تابعه
للاسطول الروسي في البحر الاسود
اليوم عند الواحده والنصف بتوقيت موسكو
اقدمت القوات الاوكرانيه على محاوله فاشله
للهجوم على السفينه
التابعه لاسطول البحر الاسود والمكلفه
بمهام مراقبه وتامين خطي انابيب ترك ستريم
حيث استخدمت في محاوله الهجوم سته زوارق
مسيره دمرت جميعها لم تسجل اي خسائر ولم
تصب السفينه باي اضرار اثناء الهجوم نفذت
طائره مسيره تابعه للقوات الجويه
الامريكيه مهمه استطلاع في المجال الجوي
للجزء الاوسط من البحر الاسود
الدكتور فولوديمي
دبلوماسيه لاوكرانيه السابق والمستشار
السابق لحاكم خيرسون ومن موسكو ينضم الينا
الباحث في المجلس الروسي للشؤون
الدوليه ونبدا معك من كييف
اذا اردنا ان نتحدث جغرافيا طبعا
المنطقه شاسعه وواسعه جدا اكان في شرق
اوكرانيا او في الجنوب والمحاور متعدده
لكن جغرافيا علامه يركز الجيش الاوكراني
حاليا
من مناطق اساسيه في هجومه المضاد
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
من خرسان انا اليوم في مدينه خرسان نعم
موجود هجوم المضاد ولكن بصراحه كما يقولون
خبراء الاوكران بان هذه ليست
هجوم على نطاق الواسع هذا عمليه هجينه او
ممكن نكون بان هذا العمليات استطلاعها
يعني اوكرانيا
لم تنافذ ولم تشون هجوم مضادات الواسع كما
في منطقه الباص وكمان في محافظه
تقدم قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا كما في محافظه
اوكرانيا اليوم حراره تقريبا طلعت وكمان
تقادم قوات مصالح اوكرانيه في جنوب
اوكرانيا في محافظه
اركان اوكرانيا اوكرانيا اليوم دمرت حوالي
68 من معادله عسكريه روسيا بعض الدبابات
ومدراعتها السيارات عسكريه الروسيه ولكن
ثانيا واحد نحن نشاهد بان روسيا تهاجمه
على قوات مصالحه اوكرانيا
قرب من منطقه في منطقه محمود على راحه
تحاول تطويق بلده محمود من الشمال ومن
جنوبه من جنوب هذا المنطقه
كما يقولون خبراء لان اوكرانيا الان ما
زال في بحث النقاط الضعف في دفاعات روسيه
معروف بين روسيا حاسده الضخم من قواتها في
منطقه
حوالي 120 الف جنديا روسيا
ساعود اليك لانه يعني هذه النقاط مهمه جدا
التي ذكرتها في سياق العمليات العسكريه
لكن اسمح لي انتقل الى سيد روكان من من
موسكو ماذا لو فعلا
واصلت القوات الروسيه عفوا القوات
الاوكرانيه تقدمها كما
تعلن كياف ماذا لو وصل التقدمها واستعاده
المزيد من البلدات والمناطق من ايدي
القوات الروسيه وحلفائها كيف سيكون انعكاس
ذلك في روسيا او في الداخل الروسي او على
معنويات الجيش الروسي عموما
ليس هنالك اي تغيير اساسي في الوضع ان
المعارك تنتقل من منطقه الى اخرى ما
نستطيع ان نؤكده اننا لم نرى اي
قتال مكثف خلال الاشهر الاخيره بالتاكيد
هو هذه هي الاجمل مضاده اساسيه الاوكرانيه
هنالك قتال يشتد يوما بعد يوم والان من
الصعب الجزم كيف ان الوضع سوف
يتكشف لان الوضع متغير يتغير بشكل
كل ساعه في حقيقه الامر
فيما يتعلق بالبلدات الثلاثه التي
استعادتها اوكرانيا اول شيء ليس هنالك اي
تاكيد الروسي رسمي ان روسيا قامت خسرت هذه
حتى اذا ما تطرقنا الى الوكالات الغربيه
علينا ان نذكر انه كان هنالك زعم بثلاث
بلدان
تمشيوشكا اذا ما ذهبت الى الانترنت لدينا
هنالك بلده
عدد سكانها اقل من 600 شخص وكان هنالك عدم
وضوح
ذكر في احد الوكالات انها
اوكرانيا استعادتها لكن خسرتها مره ثانيه
بالتالي المعلومات غير مؤكده اقول ذلك
وانا افهم واعرف تماما ان من المحتمل ان
اوكرانيا سوف
تتقدم وان اوكرانيا ستتقدم ربما وتحصل على
[موسيقى]
عشري بلدات او عشره قرى لكن علينا ان نفهم
ان القصه برمتها الام لا يتعلق بالقرى
والبلدات كما تعرفون ان الغرب استثمر في
اوكرانيا
المليارات من الدولارات اذا ما كانت كلفه
هذه هذه
الاستثمارات الضخمه عشر قرى او عشر بلدات
هذا ليس بالكافي ما تحتاجه اوكرانيا
ان يكون هنالك نصر مغير لقواعد هذا السؤال
هذا السؤال الذي كنت ساطرحه على على ضيف
من خرسون
الدكتور شوماكور سيد شوماكو باستعاده ثلاث
بلدات او حتى عشر بلدات
بوجود كل هذا الكم الكبير من الاسلحه
الغربيه الفائقه التطور هل تملك اوكرانيا
القدره العديده على الاقل لتغطيه هذه
الجبهات والاستعاده السيطره على تلك
المناطق الواسعه هذا سؤال كبير هل بامكان
اوكرانيا
ولو بوجود هذه الاسلحه بامكانها ان تحقق
هدف من هذا النوع
دعونا نتذكر بان اوكرانيا قررت 60% من
اراضها المحتله تقريبا في موسم الخريف
فنحن نتذكر هزيمه مغذيه روسيا في طقحقر من
مدينه خرسان ومن الضفه غربيه محافظه خرسون
وطردت اوكرانيا روسيا
ضخمه من الغرب وخاصه من امريكا بالمناسبه
سوف تشم هجوم مضاد قوات مصالحه وكرينيه
على روسيا بدون مقاتلات من تراس اف 16
بدون ضبابات عبر رمز وبدون صواريخ بعيده
ماذا كما طلبت اوكرانيا ينبغي ادراك بين
روسيا كما كنت قابل حشدت عن الضخم من
القواتها ولكن على كل حال اوكرانيا سوف
تفلح في طرد روس من اراضي اوكرانيا انا
شخصيا اعتقد بان اوكرانيا سوف تحتاج عده
هجومات مضادات الاطار دروس اوكرانيا
بالمناسبه للاسف الشديد روسيا اليوم دمرت
الصاد الثاني في محافظه
كبير ولكن على كل حال كما فضت بالمناسبه
اركان اوكرانيه تدمير هذا
القوات مصالحه ولم يتغير مصر
في صالح اوكرانيا من جديد
لسيد ستروكان طيب الهجمات الموضوعيه
اختراق الدفاعات
الروسيه على الجبهات الا تدل على قدره
الجانب الاوكراني فعلا على التقدم لانه
هناك خطوط جبهات موجوده خطوط دفاع لكن لو
اخترقت سيتقدم الجيش الاوكراني اكثر
بمساعده
المعدات الغربيه الحديثه ما رايك وباختصار
ارجوك
من الواضح ان اوكرانيا لديها امكانيات
كبيره بهذه الاسلحه التي تم اعطائها
لاوكرانيا الجيش الاوكراني قوي للغايه لكن
هنالك نقطه مهمله اعتقد ان من المناسب ان
نناقش ان الامر في اطار كيف كما ذكر الضيف
لانه
تعلمنا درسا من من خاركيف وهذا الامر لن
يتكرر في اي مكان اخر نحن مهيئين لهذه
الهجمه المضاده هذه النقطه الاولى النقطه
الثانيه
انا لا اعتقد
عندما يصف اي شخص الوضع من الكافي القول
انني اعمل واتمنى واعتقد ليس هذه ليست
حقائق المشكله مع المتحدثين الاوكرانيين
بدءا من الرئيس ووزير الخارجيه انهم
يتهربون من الحقائق وهم يتحدثون كثيرا
ويقولون اننا سنحقق النصر دعونا ننتظر
ونرى دعونا ننتظر ونرى كان الباحث في
المجلس الروسي لشؤون الدوليه من موسكو
شكرا جزيلا لك وشكرا لفولودمر شوماكوزا
الدبلوماسيه الاوكراني السابق والمستشار
السابق لحاكم كان معنا من خيرسون
[موسيقى]
الى تطورات الملف النووي الايراني حيث قال
المرشد الايراني علي خامنئي ان بلاده لا
تعارض ابرام اتفاقيات بشان ملف النووي
شريطه الحفاظ على البنيه التحتيه لصناعه
النوويه وعقيب زياره لمعرض انجازات
الصناعات النوويه الايرانيه في طهران اضاف
المرشد الايراني ان من وصفهم بالاعداء
يتخذون سلاح نووي ذريعه لمنع بلاده من
التقدم في المجالات العلميه
موجوده يجب الحفاظ على البنى التحتيه في
صناعتنا النوويه خلال هذه السنوات تمكنا
من تحقيق انجازات مهمه من الممكن ان تبرم
اتفاقيات في بعض الامور ولا مشكله في ذلك
لا نعارض ابرام اتفاقيات في الملف النووي
شريطه الحفاظ على البنيه التحتيه في
صناعتنا النوويه يجب ان نحافظ على هذه
الانجازات التي تحققت خلال سنوات بفضل
جهود خبرائنا
صلاه
قالت الخارجيه الامريكيه ردا على تصريحات
المرشد الايراني علي خمنائي نواشنطن
ملتزمه بعدم السماح ابدا لايران بامتلاك
سلاح النووي واضافت الخارجيه ان
الدبلوماسيه هي افضل سبيل لتحقيق هذا
الهدف لكن الرئيس بايدن كان واضحا ايضا
بشان عدم استبعاد اي خيارات مطروحه على
الطاوله
سيطرى ملف الهجره على المحادثات التي
اجراها وفد اوروبي في تونس مع الرئيس قيس
سعيد وقال بيان مشترك صدر عظيب لقاء سعيد
برئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيسه وزراء
ايطاليا ورئيس الوزراء الهولندي قال ان
الاولويه المشتركه هي مكافحه الهجره غير
النظاميه من والى تونس وكانت رئيسه
المفوضيه الاوروبيه قد قالت سن المفوضيه
ستقدم دعما فوريا لتونس بقيمه 150 مليون
يورو منها 100 مليون بهدف اداره الحدود
للحد من الهجره عبر المتوسط
الهجره غير النظاميه والتهريب والوضع
الاقتصادي في تونس قضايا دفعت رئيسه
الوزراء الايطاليه جورجيا ميلوني الى
زياره تونس للمره الثانيه خلال اسبوع رفقه
رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ورئيس الوزراء
الهولندي
يخشى الاوروبيون حسب مسؤولين ايطاليين
انهيار الاوضاع في تونس وتدفق اعداد كبيره
من اللاجئين باتجاه السواحل الاوروبيه
ولمواجهه مثل هذه الاحتمالات اعلن
الاوروبيون حزمه مساعدات ماليه لتونس
يه لمكافحه التهريب وسندعم تونس في مجال
اداره الحدود سيقدم الاتحاد الاوروبي هذا
العام 200 مليون يورو لتونس لاداره الحدود
وكذلك لعمليات البحث والانقاذ ومكافحه
التهريب وعمليه الاعاده
لكن هذا السخاء الاوروبي لم ياتي من فراغ
حسب كثير من التونسيين هنا في الولايه
صفاقس يتحين عدد كبير من اللاجئين الفرصه
للانتقال الى الجانب الاوروبي الرئيس
التونسي قيس سعيد الذي زارهم شدد على ان
حل قضيه اللاجئين الافارقه يجب الا تكون
على حساب تونس وان بلاده لن تقوم بدور
الحارس لدولهم في اشاره الى الدول الاتحاد
الاوروبي
الحل لا يمكن ان يكون الا انسانيا وجماعيا
بناء على مقاييس انسانيه ولكن في ظل
القانون
ولم تغب قضيه اللاجئين في تونس عن
المنظمات الحقوقيه التي طالبت السلطات
التونسيه مرارا بعدم تسهيل عمليات الاعاده
القصريه للاجئين لكن الضغوط الاقتصاديه
الخانقه حسب متابعين قد تدفع السلطات الى
توقيع اتفاق مع الاتحاد الاوروبي عنوانه
الرئيسي مكافحه الهجره غير النظاميه هذه
الاتفاقيات سوف تكون لها اثار وخيمه اذا
ما ذهبت نحو يعني
دعمها باتفاقيات بينيه بين الاتحاد
الاوروبي وبلدان العبور في البحر الابيض
المتوسط خاصه
للمهاجرين غير النظاميين
بكل سبل تسعى ايطاليا ومن خلفها الدول
الاوروبيه
تجنبيه التونس
يه مقاربه تلقى انتقادات واسعه من
المنظمات الحقيقيه التي تدعو الى حمايه
اللاجئين وادماجهم بدلا ترحيلهم بشكل
قصريبه الجزيره تونس
على صعيد متصل انتقد المنتدى التونسي
للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه اهداف
زياره الوفد الاوروبي الرفيع لتونس بشان
ملف الهجره وقال بيان للمنتدى ان زياره
الوفد الاوروبي الحاليه لتونس تاتي تحت
عناوين تبدو جذابه حول تعاون الاقتصادي
لكنها تخفي ابتزازا يقوم على مقيده
المساعدات الاقتصاديه بلعب دور شرطي
الحدود حسب البيان الذي قال ايضا ان
اوروبا تنظر الى تونس منذ سنوات كنقطه
حدوديه متقدمه تحتاج مزيدا من التجهيزات
لاحتواء الهجره واكد البيان ضروره ان لا
تضغط الاعتبارات الامنيه على حساب حقوق
الانسان وان تعطي اي سياسه او تعاون بشان
الهجره الاولويه لحمايه ارواح المهاجرين
وحقوقهم الانسانيه
حول هذا الموضوع معنى من تونس نسرين
بلقاسم الباحثه في المنتدى التونسيه
للحقوق الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والمختصه
في ملف الهجره غير النظاميه كما ينضم
الينا من تونس بالحسن اليحياوي الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي ابدا معك سيده نسرين يعني
لماذا
الانتقاد
لهذا التعاون الاوروبي التونسي حول ملف
الهجره اليس من مسؤوليه تونس والسلطات في
تونس ان تمنع اساسا التهريب والهجره عبر
حدودها
اول شيء اشكركم على الاستضافه لا يجب ان
نذكر ان هذه الظاهره الغير الهجره الغير
النظاميه شهدت ارتفاعا كبيره في السنوات
الاخيره وتطورا حتى على مستوى اشكال
المهاجرين اصبحت تمس جميع الفئات
الاجتماعيه في تونس وجميع الفئات العمريه
نجد حتى الاطفال والقص المهاجرون بطريقه
نظاميه وحتى العائلات الى غير ذلك ان تونس
اصبحت مصدره للمهاجرين الغير النظاميين من
جنسيات اخرى لجدو السوريين وفريقه جنوب
الصحراء ولكن
ان نعود الى مساله الانسان والانسانيه
ونحترم حقوق الانسان لا يجب ان تكون
السياسات الهجريه
تتجاوز الانسان
وتمارس على
السيده نسرين لكن سؤالي هنا من حيث المبدا
من حيث المبدا اليس من من المسؤوليه الدول
ان تمنع اي
عبور غير قانوني اكان الى اراضيها او من
اراضيها لان هناك حدود
ولان هناك اشتراطات لكل من يريد ان يعبر
الحدود اليست هذه المسؤوليه طبيعيه
هي من ناحيه هي مسؤوليه طبيعيه ولكن حريه
التنقل هو من المفروض حق يتمتع به كل
انسان يعني ليس من المفروض ان نمنع التنقل
على اي انسان لانه لا يمكن اعتباره انسان
مجرم او انساننا خطير او كما شبهه بعض
السياسيين كارهابي له نعتبره المهاجر
الغير النظامي بعض السياسات الهجريه او
بعض السياسات الدول تعتبرك انه انسان مجرم
او انسان
يخالف في القواعد ويخالف القوانين ولكن
عندما ننظر بعين الحريه في كل انسان حريه
التنقل وصعوبه حصول المواطنين على
التاشيره تجعلهم يستعملون اساليب اخرى
للتنقل مثلا في تونس نجد صعوبه كبيره في
الحصول على التاشيره للتنقل للدول
الاوروبيه لذلك المواطنون
يجدون طرق اخرى للتنقل بامكان
طريقه الهجره غير نظاميه ونجد كذلك
المهربين
يستغلون الوقت الاقتصادي والسياسي الهش في
تونس ويعتمدون
نظر السيد بالحسن اليحياوي في هذه القضيه
صيد اليحياوي يعني هل هي مقايضه ان تتلقى
تونس اموالا اوروبيه فعلا وتلعب دور شرطي
الحدود منع
الهجره من اراضيها او الى اراضيها في
النهايه هذه المساله بعمقها هي مساله
انسانيه هل لتونس هذا الدور
تحدث عن ضروره ايجاد حلول ضمن المقاربه
الانسانيه وعدم الاكتساب المقاربه الامنيه
ولكن طبعا هذا لا يعني ان تونس يجب ان
تدفع الثمن موقعها الاستراتيجي على اعتبار
انها اقرب نقطه الى السواحل الشماليه
البحر الابيض المتوسط كما ان طبيعه
سواحلها تسمح لي العصابات الدوليه
المتاجره بالبشر باتخاذها نقطه انطلاق
المهاجرين الغير النظاميين سواء كان هؤلاء
من التونسيين انفسهم القادمين من دول
الجنوب الصحراء او دول الساحل والصحراء
ايضا في الحقيقه حتى صلب الاتحاد الاوروبي
هناك اكثر من مقاربه في التعامل مع قضيه
الهجره ككل سواء كانت هذه الهجره النظاميه
او غير نظاميه وثم رايين متباينين هناك
راي تدعمه اساسا اسبانيا وايطاليا
والبرتغال في مقابل راي اخر اساسا تقوله
فرنسا التي تدفع نح معالجه هذا الامر
بمقاربه امنيه صرفه ولكن طبعا شاهدنا في
الاشهر الفارطه حتى هذا التلاسم بين
ايطاليا وبين فرنسا وتحميل فرنسا مسؤوليه
ما يحدث في القاره الافريقيه خاصه فيما
يتعلق بملف الهجره تمت مقاربه تقول انه من
الضروري احداث عمليه التنميه اقتصاديه
حقيقيه لكن انا الان اسال عن عن الدوري
التونسي يعني نحن لا نناقش مساله الهجره
والخلافات الاوروبيه بشان الهجره نحن امام
وفد اوروبي جاء الى تونس عرض اموالا تقول
منظمات حقوق الانسان ان تونس تلعب دور
شرطي الحدود مقابل الحصول على اموال
ومساعدات
هذا هو الامر المطروح حاليا ما رايك فيه
لا طبعا هذه مجرد قراءه سطحيه لهذا الوقت
الاوروبي الذي هرع الى تونس وحتى يعني
زياره الى تونس الامر لا يتعلق فقط بملف
الهجره غير النظاميه وانما يتعلق بموقف
تونس ككل من الشراكه مع الاتحاد الاوروبي
تونس لوحت في مناسبات عده اتخذت خطوات نحو
استبدال الشركاء التقليديين على المستوى
الاقتصادي طبعا يعني نقصد الصين ونقصد
روسيا ونقصد غير ذلك وتعلمون ان مجرد نطق
اسم روسيا الان في الاتحاد الاوروبي يقف
له شعر الجميع ولذلك كل هذه الوعود
واسميها طبعا وعود لان وصولها الى ان
تتحقق يبدو امرا صعب المنال كل هذه الوعود
بالمساعدات الاقتصاديه والحديث عن قرابه
900 مليون يورو مساعدات اقتصاديه لتونس
طبعا هذا يدخل ضمن هذا الابتزاز المتبادل
تونس الى حد هذه اللحظه لم تلعب ورقه
النظاميين كما حدث منذ سنوات مثلا في
تركيا وبفضل اماكن التركيه من 6 مليار
دولار لم نصل الى هذه النقطه بعد لا زالت
السلطه في تونس تتعامل مع هذا الملف
الكثير واضح اتضحت الفكره سيده سيده نسرين
المساله لم تصل الى حد الابتزاز كما يقول
ضيفنا ولا يلغي الرئيس قيس سعيد الجانب
الانساني في هذه القضيه وبالتالي ربما
يكون في
المنظمات الحقوقيه التي تعاملت مع الموضوع
شيء من المبالغه والتخوف ما رايك
يجب دائما ان ننسى الجانب الانساني في كل
الحالات رغم المفاوضات والاتفاقيات ورغم
ما يخفى وراء هذه الاتفاقيات لاننا دائما
نجد هناك غموض بعض الاحيان في ماء وراء
الاتفاقيات وفيما وراء هذه المفاوضات
ودائما الضحيه يكون المهاجر الغامدي اما
انت تم معاملته
في مراكز
الايواء او الاحتجاز ونجد بعض الوفيات
التي تكون لهم العديد من الغموض كذلك نجد
الترحيل القصري يجب دائما ان تتعامل
الدوله التونسيه مع ملف الهجره اولا
باحتراما للانسان وللمواطن مهما كانت
جنسيته او مهما كانت وضعيته وضعيته في
سواء كان في الدول الاوروبيه او
اللاجئين في يجب دائما ان نحترم الانسان
المهاجر
ويتمتع بجميع حقوقه لا يجب ان يكون الضحيه
هو المهاجر غير النظام شكرا جزيلا لكن
بلقاسم الباحثه في المنتدى التونسي للحقوق
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والمختصه في ملف
الهجره غير النظاميه حدثنا من تونس وشكرا
بالحسن اليحياوي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
كان معنا من تونس ايضا
[موسيقى]
عوده مشاهدينا الى السودان حيث دخلت
المعارك بين الجيش والدعم السريع مرحله ما
يمكن وصفه لحرب الجسور فما اهميه الجسور
في السيطره على الخرطوم الكبرى تضم
العاصمه السودانيه ثلاث مدن هي الخرطوم
والخرطوم بحري واندرمان تربط بينها عشره
جسور نهريه خمسه منها على نهر النيل
الازرق وثلاثه على نهر النيل الابيض
وجسران على نهر النيل تعتبر الجسور
المؤديه نحو القصر الجمهوري ومقر القياده
العسكريه ومطار الخرطوم اكثر اهميه
استراتيجيه لان السيطره عليها تحرم الطرف
الاخر من حريه الحركه والمناوره من والى
مركز العاصمه
جسر حلفايه او كوبري حلفايه الذي تتضارب
روايتها طرفي النزاع بشان السيطره عليه
يعتبر واحدا من اكبر الجسور في البلاد
واكثرها اهميه يقع الجسر في شمال الخرطوم
ويبلغ طوله اكثر من 900 متر وعرضه حوالي
30 مترا بحيث يتسع لسته مسارات
ويطلع الجسر بدور حيوي في حركه التنقل بين
مدينتي الخرطوم بحري واندرمان وازدادت
اهميته في النزاع باعتباره طريقا لنقل
التعزيزات العسكريه والامدادات وشهد جسر
حلفايه قبل نحو شهر احدى اعمى في المعارك
منذ اندلاع النزاع استخدم فيها سلاح الجو
من قبل الجيش لقصف قوات الدعم السريع
المتمركزه في المنطقه
للمزيد ينضموا الينا هنا في الاستوديو
الدكتور عيدروس اسامه عيدروس الاكاديمي
السوداني
المختص في الشؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
مرحبا بك دكتور
يعني تبعنا
عرض
قصير حول الجسور واهميه الجسور لكن جسر
حلفايه الان هل السيطره عليه من قبل اي من
الطرفين يغير مجرى المعارك في العاصمه
الخرطوم
جسر الحلفايه اول شيء هو الجيش يغلقه من
الجهه الغربيه منذ فتره طويله يعني ليست
حديثه والحركه فيه يعني
منسابه بالجهه الشرقيه يوجد قوات للدعم
السريع بالجهه الغربيه يوجد الجيش منذ
فتره طويله اهميه الجسر انه المنطقه
الاساسيه
ولايه الخرطوم بها السبعه مناطق عسكريه
اساسيه يعني في سلاح الاسلحه والمنطقه
العسكريه
الوسطى في بحري وفي المنطقه العسكريه
الخرطوم وتشمل القياده العامه وفي سلاح
المدرعات وفي قاعده وادي سيدنا والمهندسين
بالاضافه لموقع مهم في جنوب الخرطوم هو
موقع الاحتياطي المركزي دارت فيه معارك
ايضا قريبا بعض الصدمه الاولى كان اول
نجاح للجيش انه دمر المعسكرات حول
وادي سيدنا العسكريه وهذه القاعده الجويه
التي ينطلق منها الطيران الحربي وكانت في
جبل سيركاب هذه كانت معرفه مهمه جدا للجيش
وهذا المعسكر كان من الاهميه في نفس الوقت
الذي تم في تدمير المعسكر تم اغلاق الجهه
الغربيه من جسر الحلفايه طيب هي هذه
المرحله كانت بعض امتصاص الصدمه عمل الجيش
على اغلاق كل الجسور الرابطه بين الخرطوم
وغربها ما عدا جسر
الشنبات يعني جسر الشمبان توري كم مفتوحه
لتقديرات من الجيش او لعدم مقدرته على
السيطره عليه لماذا الان يعني بدت اهميه
الجسور وبدا الحديث عن معركه الجسور ومن
الذي يسيطر على هذا الجسر وعلى ذاك الجسر
بينما كنا في بدايه
المشهد العسكري كان الحديث حول القياده
العامه حول القصر الجمهوري الان بدا
الحديث عن مناطق محدده وقطع المناطق وكانه
هناك محاولات لخلق خطوط تماس بين الطرفين
في مدن العاصمه
اولا الدعم السريع استراتيجيته حققت بعض
النجاحات في الخرطوم ونجده يعني في
الاستراتيجيه وفي
مصنع اليرموك في الفتره السابقه الان توجه
بكلياته للعمل في جنوب الخرطوم محاولا
يعني الاستفاده من هذا النجاح
واسقاط المدرعات هذا الامر يعني مع
الاستنزاف الكبير من خلال العمليات
النوعيه للجيش ومن خلال المعارك الكثيره
التي دارت يعني جعل منطقه بحري يعني
اعدادهم تقل فيها بشكل كبير خروج الجيش
وحركه الجيش يعني الجيش ظهر الان بالمشاه
وظهرت لاول مره ايضا على الارض المدرعات
تحركت جسر الحلفايه شاركت في مدرعات وفي
مدرعات خرجت من مدرعات الخرطوم وقامت
بالتمشيط
الذي حدث يعني في كبري الحلفايه الاراء
نفسها متضاربه هل بدا الدعم السريع
بمحاوله العبور غربا الى وادي سيدنا ام ان
الجيش هو الذي بادر بالهجوم الى الشرق لكن
النتيجه هي سيطره الجيش على شرق كبري
الحلفايه بالتزامن مع تحرك في منطقه الحاج
يوسف في الشرق النيل بالتزامن مع حركه
تمشيط واسعه حول المدرعات سؤال وبختصار
شديد اذا اردنا ان نتحدث عن الجسور وتم
قطع هذه الجسور ومنع المرور عبرها الى اي
مدى يتاثر المدنيون
هو في حاله استلام الجيش لهذه الجسور لا
تتاثر حركه المدنيين اذا اصبحت اذا اصبحت
هي يعني مكان المعركه
هي يمكن ان تكون مكان المعركه لكن بالنسبه
للجيش الان هو حقق سيطره على الجسور التي
يريدها ما عدا كبري شمبات وكبر شمبات هو
الكبري الوحيد الذي يمثل منفذ للدعم
السريع اذا قامت دعم السريع
بمعركه في كبر شمبات وعطل فيه الحركه
سيكون هو الذي خنق نفسه لذلك لن تقوم هذه
المعرفه واظن الجيش يفتحها لهم لتكون مسار
للهروب ان الدعم السريع العام كانه نمر
جريح واعمى يضرب في كل الاتجاهات محاصرته
كثيرا يعني يمكن ان تحدث الكثير من الدمار
شكرا استراتيجيه الجيش الان في التمركز في
نقاط حاكمه استعداد لمرحله قادمه هذه ليست
المعركه النهائيه ولا قريب منها شكرا لك
دكتور اسامه قديم السياسي السوداني المختص
في شؤون السياسيه والعسكريه
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا ناخذكم الى اسيا الوسطى هذه
الليله على مدار 30 عاما الماضيه ارتفعت
درجات الحراره هناك بمقدار درجه ونصف
مئويه اي ضعف المتوسط ما التداعيات حالات
جفاف متكرره بشكل متزايد بينما تفتقر
بلدان هذه المنطقه الى وسائل للمواجه
التطور المؤسف الاحدث لهذا الوضع شهدته
غابات في شمال شرق قزاخستان هذا البلد
الواقع في اسيا الوسطى على الحدود مع
روسيا والذي تبلغ مساحه خمسه اضعف فرنسا
اتت الحرائق على 60 الف هكتار من الغابات
لكن الامر المحزن هو الخساره البشر 14 من
عمال الغابات لقوا مصرعهم بعدما حاصرتهم
النيران القرب من الحدود الروسيه
نتذكر من يلقون حذفهم خلال اداء مهامهم في
مهن شاقه ونتذكر ايضا تغير اسبابه
وتداعياته على كوكبنا بطبيعه الحال شكرا
لكم على حسن المتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]